foreign
comes from Thomas in Maine Thomas writes
I've done all that I can
oh I love it when a sentence starts when
something starts out that's pretty
definite yep I've explained to the
babies
I need to stop interrupting but I can
already tell you where this is headed
I've done all that I can I've explained
the baby steps without rudeness or anger
I've never tried to control my wife
I helped her pay off nine credit cards
everything was fine and we were on fire
until about a month ago then my wife
started using credit cards we had
already paid off and just got another
one in the mail yesterday
I was told my money is none of Dave
Ramsey's business and none of yours
so she's decided it's Christmas time and
she's gonna do what she wants my wife
has a master's degree in Communications
she refuses to take a job that uses her
degree so instead of her making three to
six thousand dollars a month she makes
two thousand dollars a month at a job
with no benefits my wife also has
student loans that are now officially
none of my business I'm very confused
very hurt and angry my instinct is to
give up and in the marriage this isn't
the first money argument we've had and
it won't be our last I don't see where
we're going financially or in our
marriage am I wrong for being angry
about this situation
whoo
honestly if if Thomas was here and he
just said this to me I would stop I
would take out my headphones my my
earpieces and I would give Thomas a hug
like it's just hard
it's just hard
um it sounds like he is at resent the
resentment and that's a hard place to be
in your relationship it's hard place to
come back from
um Dave I can I I don't know a lot but I
can guarantee this this isn't about
money
this is about something else going on in
their relationship oh this is about
control yeah and power and explaining
power struggle yeah and has been ongoing
for a long time right and so he
weaponized me
yeah
weaponized Dave Ramsey in your house
I'll just tell you it doesn't work okay
if you go around and say Dave Ramsey
said nobody gives a crap what Dave
Ramsey says they truly don't uh what
they care about is is information
that'll change their life
that's what they care about and they
don't care that it came from me it adds
no it's it does not it you know if you
turn my name into a cuss word or Ramsay
in general into a cuss word in your
house you did not accomplish a thing and
that so this is about control
if this marriage is gone unless you guys
get some in-depth counseling because you
are both uh have crossed the line of the
The Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse as
Les perrett talks about in his marriage
seminars
um one of them is contempt
and contempt if when you reach a
relationship with anyone where you look
at them with an eye roll
that it means you are contemptuous of
them it means you have completely lost
any respect for them your need to serve
them
and love them is just gone this is all
about I have to tolerate your presence
and you stink you need a bath it starts
to feel that way that's the way the
sound's done it absolutely and it's it's
coming both directions right oh yeah
yeah swipe is doing this back yeah she's
completely had it with him and dude you
can say I've done all that I can explain
this with baby steps or without rudeness
or anger and then the last line in the
email is Am I Wrong to be angry
there's a little inconsistency here
you've been pissed about this stuff a
long time
and um and you've you know she has a
degree in Communications and refuses to
use it that's true
but not about her career
she sucks at communication but also
people will they will cash out their
dreams they will cash out their
professional Ambitions to prove a point
right they will drive themselves into
debt because you're not gonna tell me
what to do yeah you said this is about
power and this is about I'm tired of you
talking down to me this is about I'm
tired of you telling me how I have to do
whatever is this is a marriage that is
hanging on by a yeah been a lot of uh
you should you need twos in this house
both of your Gunners both of you instead
of uh Hey what if we
looked out there and saw a really bright
place in the future and we walked
towards it together
that's a much more persuasive
methodology then you know if you'd get a
good job instead of working at half of
what you're worth we could clean this
mess up you lazy woman well if you would
just if you'd quit talking down to me
explain it's my money Dave Ramsey can
kiss my butt
and we're just gonna do this in circles
and in circles and in circles uh what's
our buddy that did that love and respect
he calls it the crazy cycle oh yeah yeah
it builds on itself and it just spins
the tornado that's right it spins out
it's uh what is it uh Elder yeah
uh gosh I'll have to go look it up there
love and respect is a great book it's a
great marriage book so Thomas this is
this is when I talk about your situation
bad yes and you've got to stop to fight
this is when you walk in and you lay
down your sword you lay down your shield
and say I'm not fighting you anymore
because this isn't about a fight
this is about getting on the same page
yeah if we can't get on the same page
this is over this is a civil war and
we're now we're just shooting grenades
at each other and we're going to end up
killing our family and our friends and
our neighbors
in the Civil War in the United States
family shot family that's right and
that's right friend shot friend that's
what you're doing yeah stop stop don't
fire another weapon
just go sit down on her side of the
couch and say listen you're not wrong to
be angry but it's not working for you
yeah
stop explaining you guys are gonna get
some help you're in eye roll you're in
contempt it is one of the four things
that ends relationships permanently
contempt is very hard to come back from